hey everyone this is our first video
update we are now starting week one of
the course I think that what will
probably say now more than anything else
is a quick conversation about the
equipment many of you are concerned that
I'm being a little too picky and what
I'm requiring of you now first of all I
am NOT requiring anything of you what
I'm doing is showing you what I do and
my technique my hope is that you'll like
what I make the images that I make and
follow my lead and for the most part the
exercises that we've developed really
are intended to be used with a 105 macro
lens on my camera that can take lenses
it is not going to work for you if
you're going to just use a snap and
shoot or whatever you call it these days
you really want to meet the standards if
I could say that that we are suggesting
you pay attention to it is true that you
can on occasion use extension tubes
instead of for example let's say you
don't have as much of a macro lens as
you'd like and so you can use it to
extensions it's law as long as they
don't have any glass but you're going to
be using F sorry you'll be losing
f-stops in the process and you'll find
out more about aperture and f-stops in
the on coming weeks so those of you who
are technically savvy I hope that you'll
find what our exercises have become
developed into and the ideas in the
course will be appropriate for your
needs as well but yeah just getting back
to the equipment I for example when we
get up to using a camera and a lens
which is in week 2 you're going to see
that I'm going to suggest using software
and you'll probably say why is she doing
that will
like to hope that I'm going to be making
a case for that so in the end please
consider following what we're suggesting
it works for me and my hope is that what
works for me is going to work for you
but this coming week we're going to have
more fun in the sense it's you're not
going to work that hard because you're
going to be using a flatbed scanner and
you're going to be a bit shocked at some
of the wonderful images you can get from
that so in any event we hope we're going
to create something wonderful for you
have fun this week